this is the Jocko underground podcast
with Echo Charles sitting across the
table from me and I am Jaco willink
control alt delete do you remember
control alt delete is that still a thing
it is okay so I use an apple
computer system so what is yours command
well what's interesting is here's what's
interesting
straight up honestly when you have a
Apple computer you don't even really
remember what the reset button is
because it doesn't happen very often and
I know there's some software engineer
reason for this kernels is that is that
something to do with kernels I don't
know what kernels I don't know either
but the way the Apple system is designed
it
doesn't get J get it doesn't get jammed
up as much as the Windows operating
system okay that's just this those are
just facts bro sure when I went I went
on deployment one time before I went on
deployment I use that I use Windows my
whole life like most people right I
guess most people
at the time most people were using
Windows and in the military is 100
Windows they don't want no apples
and I was going on deployment
and somebody one of my friends just kept
telling me Apple Apple app I like hype
hype hype hype right so finally I got my
wife
on Apple computer before I went on
deployment
and when I came home and so I got it set
up for and it's a little different it's
a little bit different you know you're
kind of a little bit unsure there's some
techniques
that are different have you ever even
used an apple yes sir okay so I didn't
know these techniques but got the things
set up for my wife
I come home from deployment what six
seven months later come home
and
the computer is on whatever and I'm like
working with it and for some reason it
came up I said well how you know
how many times have you had to restart
this she said
zero
zero times the computer was up and
running for six straight months now hula
wasn't like it's under massive stress of
high level computations
but sure enough the thing kept up and
running and when I because a Windows
computer at that time this is like 2003
2004. if you've got a Windows computer
you were resetting that thing maybe once
every other day you had to you had to do
what I'm talking about which is a little
bit of the old control alt delete I
don't know what that thing is on a Apple
computer on the Apple computer I usually
just turn it off I just hold the power
button down if something goes wrong
which doesn't go wrong for months for
months stays up and running
does your Windows computer stay up and
running uh no you're I'm what I'm
thinking about your whole scenario I'm
like what are you doing that makes you
have to go control delete even on a
Windows no but this is back in the day
back in the day and then it must have
been like kind of a clunky computer
probably yeah I mean okay a video
editing okay yeah you put in some higher
high resolution freaking files yeah and
then you start trying to do effects and
all at the same time oh yeah control
delete for sure but not Jocko in 2004.
one email and a Word document why am I
is that thing locking up yeah unless
you're opening some spam or something
like this where you know how they send
you the spam and you would execute I
don't know but but you know when I was
going to college the only thing I'd like
just to put in perspective truly the
only thing I would be doing on these
things was literally I don't think I've
ever edited a video maybe I've edited
now I've edited a couple on my phone
on my telephone I'd edit a video now
yeah because I got skills
a little bit different but yeah yeah for
sure so control alt delete or power down
what are these things for these are
these are like physical actions that you
can take
when the software on your computer or on
your phone or on your printer is
confused or locked up or bogged down
with
too much information or not enough
information or it's just going into
brain freeze right that's what happens
is that why it happens because I don't
really know I'd say that's a good
analogy for sure
so what you do is you override the
software
with the hardware with the hard shutdown
you override it you say Hey listen all
these little weird ones and zeros that
you've got going on where does we're
just cutting the power that's what you
do you override it
well the same thing actually happens to
us as humans see what I'm saying I can
see you're not in your head you're not
in your head you're like yes doc was on
this we in our own heads
in our own heads we get bogged down
we get distractions we get
rationalizations going on we get debates
going on in your own head and what I'm
telling you now is that the solution to
these
brain
Cycles
where they get caught in a continuous
cycle of distraction or continuous cycle
of rationalization or whatever
the solution is the same
it's a hard
action that you have to do to to
it's a manual override we have the
capability of manually overriding our
software
and the way you do that is by taking
action so
it's again here's the problem like if
imagine if the if the computer had a a
robot arm a robot hand let's say and it
was aimed there's a finger on the robot
hand and it was aimed at the button sure
wait which button
[Music]
so it's
[Laughter]
it's aimed at that
and if you're in normal operating you
could say oh shut the computer down and
that robot hand would press the button
right okay cool but we need some brain
freeze it can't even do that right right
it just it's just locked up
that happens to us in our brains right
we know we're supposed to work out
and we just go into lock mode we know
we're we're supposed to go talk to our
subordinate about
the fact that they're late for the third
time and you know you should do it but
instead you just go into brain lock
maybe your wife's doing something that's
could be detrimental to the relation
right
sure and you know you should say
something even you know you should take
an indirect approach but you know you
need to contend with this scenario
that's happening yeah but what do you do
nothing brain lock so you freeze so what
I'm saying is you can actually do a
manual override of these situations and
you can you need to make yourself
take action
so you're saying take action in that
direction that you're intentionally or
intending to yes take action in that
direction that you know you should and
but the hard part about it is
your brain is the one that's controlling
that robot finger that's the hard part
yeah you have to you have to that's why
you have to be able to detach from it
you have to be able to take a step
outside of your software system and just
slam your fist onto that finger and make
that thing hit reset which means when
the alarm clock goes off in the morning
get up
don't wait don't hesitate when the alarm
clock goes off in the morning get up
when you get into the gym like set you
know what here's here's here's an
example when we're gonna roll the Jiu
Jitsu
when we come in when everyone gets on
the mat I immediately start the clock
for five minutes to start stretching
right you have five minutes to stretch
if you don't put a clock on that how
long are we stretching for forever
it could be a long time because you know
people are stretching they're kind of
talking oh yeah they got things
real important stuff that's real that's
real so when you go in there start the
clock you should put a you should put a
timer on everything that you do
basically I agree basically that's what
should be happening everything that you
do you should say all right I have to
commence you should be a countdown to go
and then a certain amount of time to get
her done
that's the way you need to operate that
takes you out of this software brain
lock that you can get inside your own
head yeah
so that's my recommendation
yeah you um that that's such a good idea
the clock thing so even workouts because
we're on the same way well I know you
already know that about me because I'm
the one number one culprit with the
talking thing well you you ever seen
when I I I'll put like uh a post on the
ground yes and I'll say something like
uh
hesitated
stretched
procrastinating you know I'll be
especially on let's face it on on leg
day when we're squatting yeah
can spend an inordinate amount of time
stretching yeah you can spend in order
amount of time checking your form you
know with the PVC pipe you know you're
just doing all kinds of dumb stuff
because you know because you know what
you should be doing yeah so you need to
get over that yeah
yeah you have five minutes to stretch
son yeah and that's like well I mean
obviously depends on your body but five
minutes that's a long time a solid right
there again depends so that don't but um
yeah if you don't and it depends on what
kind of person you are but yeah if you
got other stuff on your mind especially
if you have other stuff on your mind
don't let it be like three four things
on your mind and then now you gotta go
focus on something meanwhile these
things pull and then yeah you get that
weird brain lock thing
um
what you think about this so
I thought when I first when you first
started going into it control delete I
was like oh yeah that's like a vacation
you take a vacation
yes that's what it is in a way you know
you know your mind it's always in the
tropics I was gonna say the gutter but
it's actually the chopper it's actually
down at the beach 100 it's actually over
by the pool so you got uh chronic what's
the two chronic and acute we'll say so
it feels like you're talking about like
acute brain lock we'll call it for lack
of it but if you've got chronic brain
lock where it's like you can't think of
this direction where you need to go or
this life yeah your whole life yeah
and you feel like because you know you
can get and it's like a version of
tunnel vision or whatever where you're
like going in this direction you're like
man it's not it's not like I can't
figure this thing out whatever Direction
you're going in and you've been working
at it for how long and it's still not
just it's not producing
and then
you a lot of times Your solution is to
detach because from a different
perspective you're like oh shoot I
missed all this other stuff and then
boom but vacation in a big way depends
on where you go depends on what you're
doing it depends on who you with but
vacation in a big way can provide that
then why aren't you coming up with Nobel
prize winning ideas on a regular basis
homie you should have hear cancer by now
bro
anyway
it's true though think about it even if
you physically go like super high like
on a mountain or something like that
like it'll kind of provide that for your
brain it's true that is true uh
what you said about me detaching to find
a solution the problem yeah I was
talking about this on the academy the
other day and what I said was this
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it cost eight
dollars and 18 cents a month and if you
can't afford to support us we can still
support you just email
us at Jocko underground.com and we'll
get you taken care of until then we will
see you mobilized
Underground